right now houck
to throw his first pitch of the season
doesn't waste any time first pitch into
center field and cedric mullins has his
third hit of the young season
94 miles an hour high fly ball hernandez
[ __ ] will run it down
to retire the side so how gets through
it one left and the red sox are coming
up looking for that first run
and matt harvey the first start for the
orioles
coming off uh i guess what brandon hyde
and you know in texting with matt he
said
seem to get better every time out so
again not the guy that you know came up
with the mets throwing 97 to 99 but as
you know a lot of people have said
fastball you know 91 to 95 still
jd martinez the dh
high fly ball that one driven to the
left backing up hayes on the track and
can't see it it bounces on the warning
track
he was blinded by it and jd walks into
second base
well he did look lost he put that glove
up he's got the sunglasses on he's got
everything he needs the bill of the cap
but he still could not see it goes back
to the wall and just completely lost
that baseball in the sun here uh the
april sun at fenway park martinez's
second double of the series and that
gets boguards to the plate
breaking ball popped up
galvez back
tough sun you can see him working it too
red sox retired no damage
rio ruiz to lead things off here tanner
houck into his second inning
and there's another one to put him away
and he struck him out for his second k
that one was west east also starts it on
the outside part of the plate actually
off the outside corner and ends up off
the inside corner
swaying and a miss 96
that would have been a strike anyway he
dotted that outside corner now see that
last fastball is harder than any
fastball we saw him throw last year he
reached back for a little bit extra
there and picked up the strikeout
swing and a miss on a high rider and he
strikes out the side
tanner houck is off to the races
pumped in there and he has fanned
another one it's four straight five in
the game and coming right after him with
the fastball again to pick up the
strikeout that's three straight
strikeouts now
on his fastball
tanner houck from the stretch
swinging at a miss 95 so he came two in
that inning three
in the second and a man in the first and
they're piling up
and now an rbi chance for franco
one two to franco
bounced up the middle and into center
field
base hit two runs will score
and the orioles are on top two nothing
as new oriole michael franco delivers
yeah hits it where nobody's playing
not a particularly bad pitch but just
good at hitting you try to hit the ball
back up the middle especially
against a guy like how you're trying to
stay on everything i mean
it's been one of those swing and miss
afternoon so just to ground off the
middle is something
to crow about as it turns out because of
the
past ball and the error that they just
like yesterday take advantage of an
error and put two runs on the board
second look at harvey here for jd
martinez
ground that one into left field for a
base hit past the sprawling galvez so
good start jd's two for two all right
let's go
[Music]
line driving a base hit to right keep
the line moving
martinez to second and two on for rafael
devers like when i well like what uh
bogot stood there you know not trying to
get too big
let's get into the groove of this thing
take this fastball take it to the
opposite field
little tapper first base line mancini
will go for the tag and get him that'll
advance the runners
borrowing gonzalez had a base hit in the
second inning one for one with a steal
i fly ball that one headed toward the
triangle that's driven out there pretty
good backing up santander
jd martinez gonna tag and he is in to
score
red sox at last on the board that'll
make it 2-1
marwin gonzalez with the rbi and the
orioles have a runner third one out for
trey mancini
oh nice play by bogarts keeps the runner
at third and he gets the out at first he
froze severino with a dynamite plays
u-70 infield in yeah beautiful beautiful
play watch him go to his right then make
contact with the baseball check that
runner he's not going now go across the
diamond and get the out so the red sox
let it have it pay off by bringing the
infield in with the one out
push pitch swinging the backhand does he
have time to recover no he doesn't
santander
safe at first and severino
scores yeah to make it 3-1 yeah bogart
just knocks it down can't make it up
anthony santander runs well
hardest play in baseball the backhand
jd is two for two with a double and a
single
3-1 orioles one strike pitch
that one off of the pitch that's going
to carry him into the open space
runner trying to score here's the throw
home and he will
plawecki comes plowing in
on a carom by jd martinez
and the red sox pick up another run now
three to two
well jd picks up his third hit of the
day and red sox catch a break here it's
gonna go right off the pitcher and right
into an open space
and that's going to allow powecky to
come across the score
so jd with his third hit
red sox finally getting to harvey a
little bit
turns freddie galvez around the switch
hitter from the right side lines one
into the gap in left field
cordova over to cut it off with a lead
off hit freddie galvez has his first hit
of the game look out upstairs and gets
away so galvez advances on the wild
pitch
breaking ball he lines it into left
field galvez will have to stay at third
arrow
wow i don't know what that was through a
lollipop and almost allowed the runner
to move up
oh he hit it hard that'll get him home
caught out in right field
by verdugo and it's a sacrifice rbi for
trey mancini great at bat
head to the bottom of the ninth that
fenway orioles on top four to two and
cesar valdez on to close it out for the
birds
[Music]
get him on the foot yeah
it hit him
and
red sox have that base runner
last thing you want to do right here
ball four
red sox have runners at first and second
and nobody out
[Applause]
he struck him out he came back to get
cordero hole for four today and a big
first down for baltimore
pine runs
on board winning run at the plate
and that's hit well left field coming in
hard
there is austin hayes hit it on a line
two down
0-2 one more time a little flare to
second
ureas over to first and the orioles win
it
valdez escapes after the red sox got the
first two runners aboard and the orioles
win it 4-2